early on with with development of mafia
3 we knew we needed a city that could be
treated as a main character we wanted to
see that was a conic a city that had a
lot of history to it but also felt very
different from Empire Bay which is kind
of an amalgamation of a couple different
cities but most often is associated with
like Chicago and New York and then also
something that we could look at and say
well the the really the time period
really resonates with it right by that
point we kind of knew that we were gonna
be at least somewhere in the 60s we
didn't know exactly where yet or how
many years would pass but we knew we
wanted to be in 60s you know we kind of
cast around with a lot of different
ideas and and when the idea of New
Orleans came up it really was the
perfect city because it checked off all
those boxes Norland is a very iconic
American city like you know you see the
wrought iron you know work on the
buildings you see a picture of the
French Quarter you immediately know that
it's New Orleans if for me it's always
had this kind of and this has changed me
over the course of the project want to
start the project it was very very like
mysterious to me it was it was sort of
dangerous and sexy and it had this sort
of like this heat that pervaded not just
you know physical heat but this kind of
the sense that everything was kind of
exciting and dangerous
video games often depict American cities
in digital form Los Angeles DC Boston
Chicago and New York have all played
host to open-world games but with mafia
3 hangar 13 is venturing down to New
Orleans a city foreign to many Americans
it's a lively place it's a balmy place
New Orleans is a city that absent flows
and in mafia 3 it takes on new meaning
in the form of new Bordeaux hangar 13's
fictionalize metropolis and the first
truly open world in the Mafia series the
city is always its own character it's
always like you know has its own vibe
for me it was always about how do I boil
down the experience both as a tourist
level understanding and as somebody who
has lived there I'm very fortunate and
we have a not director across the way
who is actually grew up in New Orleans
so that was a great place a great way
for me to go and test my ideas and say
hey I'm looking for something there's a
little bit not off the beaten path or
not something that tourists understand
looking at what booking help me out with
it was always about to come back to that
idea of like for most people playing the
game they're not that familiar with it
beyond a certain superficial
understanding so I wanted to make sure
that that was always there as a reminder
for them and then as they progressed
through the hours and hours a narrative
they get to discover the city in the
same way that you know a lot of the team
did going down the chute in the
reference footage and going out and
doing that research you know having
never made a film I it's hard to compare
I don't know how much research goes into
making a film but I can only imagine
that you know the level of research and
the amount of research we did for this
game it feels like it was three films
worth of research pulling from all these
very kind of disparate sources and just
you know a lot of us just kind of tone
inspiration his remains were found in
the trunk of an old car both legs were
broken so many times there was barely
any bone left so we watched you know
dozens and dozens of documentaries we
read hundreds of books not just on the
mom but on you know everything from
voodoo to you know the South to Vietnam
and and you know kind of what the
mentality of a Vietnam vet coming back
might be like political corruption I
mean it was all across the board
Tarantino is a big influence for us you
know the way that he handles music in
particular
he takes certain tracks and kind of
reinvent them by putting them into
certain scenes and there's always that
weird discord you know everyone you know
almost every Tarantino movie has that
one track that is very discordant you
know where you're like this doesn't
really fit like the music doesn't really
fit the scene but somehow it really
works and so we looked for things like
that to continue the gameplay
I think building up a soundscape for
cities is a really important thing to do
it's um one of the ways we achieve that
is we build all these different layers
of ambience so we'll have these
background mid-ground foreground
ambience levels and they're all they're
all kind of moving and blending from
district to district now you have some
neighborhoods that are kind of more
wealthy in a nice manicured lawns and
you might hear people mowing their lawn
and gardening and you've got more
industrial areas where you'll hear like
the shipyard sounds and cranes and
machinery and then you've got the value
which has a lot of fun and wildlife and
cicadas and that kind of stuff but then
we also knew that we had it too we had
to adopt it to our own needs right so we
decided that you know it wasn't gonna be
New Orleans and in keeping with the
franchise where it's it's always
fictional cities we really wanted to
kind of make it our own so it's our
version of New Orleans I'm in Frisco
fields and need some new wheels one
thing we talked about water just the the
city streets you know widening the city
streets and giving the city some
elevation so that it's more fun to drive
he built a whole underground network of
tunnels which again is nowhere near the
reality of New Orleans but we wanted to
make it so that you could drive boats
around there and and play up this idea
of kind of bootlegging and during the
Prohibition era and the idea of pirates
and all these other things are kind of
cool elements in New Orleans we brought
the swamp and really close to the city
so that we have the bayou and you can go
out and feed alligators feed people the
alligators and swamps right so you know
so we did a lot of things like that and
then we created its own history as well
we always needed to remind the player
the city that they were in and that kind
of really started to inform even how we
laid out the city most people's concept
of New Orleans and they go there is that
what's the French Ward French Quarter
the by you those things resonate the
people so you know it's no mistake that
our version of the French Quarter is
slap bang in the middle of a city and it
forces the player to constantly
crisscross it as they move around
it's just that visual reminder of the
place that you're in
yeah well the car radio system is
something we put a lot of time into we
um we decided early on we wanted to make
it act like a real radio system so for
example if you're listening to one
station you get out of the car and go
across the street and you walk into a
bar that's clean the same station you're
going to hear that same song with the
amount of time that's traveled since you
left your car and we wanted to build out
full radio stations with you know
station IDs and commercials and news
broadcasts that change and evolve based
on what the player does
we consider the story historical pulp
fiction and one of the ways we really
approach that is the interweaving of
real-world historical events with
fictional events in the game so as you
drive around the car we have a lot of
real-world news stories you hear on the
radio it's everything from hey this
major battle occurred in Vietnam there's
you know the Civil of the housing fair
housing portion of the Civil Rights Act
was passed in 1968 there's discussions
of that pulp culture and everything kind
of in between and I think what that
really does is help ground our narrative
in the real world so that when we lay
our fiction on top of that it makes it
feel real economists get engaged you
think I give it about some politicians
going on Mafia three takes place in
Newport Oh because we really haven't had
the opportunity to see what crime looks
like in the south I think not very many
games have been able to or willing to
explore that that space you know Bill
talked about this a little bit earlier
but New Orleans in the south in general
we're sort of where the Mafia had a
wonderful foothold
following the Civil War and so being
able to kind of reflect a little bit of
that history in our present in 1968 was
just a tremendous opportunity to be able
to show here is is this this deeply
rooted history and here's how its kind
of manifest you know almost 200 years
later but Lincoln stops them keep some
Opera until the MPs show up if he was
gonna kill that flag esurance
of course need to kill Libya marcano I
wanted to feel dangerous I wanted to
feel sexy I wanted to feel I tracked
every one it's like that you know you
kind of want to touch the fire it's
gonna burn you when you touched it that
kind of thing it's it's all about these
kind of contrasts it's about what you
see on the surface was what's going on
behind the scenes
this is one thing I think people don't
know and I didn't even know until we
start research on this project but you
know the New Orleans has a long rich
history with the Italian mob it was
actually one of the first cities that
had you know kind of an Italian mafia
and going all the way back to kind of a
black hand and and then that evolving
into the more traditional mafia and at
one point this guy Carlos Marcello was a
kind of traditional Italian mobster but
he was so removed from and so powerful
that he didn't really have to answer to
the Commission you know he or the five
families you know he kept him updated
and whatnot but you know he kind of
operated with with
you know a large degree of autonomy that
a lot of the other kind of heads of the
various families didn't get Carlos
Marcello who is the Godfather real world
Godfather New Orleans and you know one
of our big inspirations for Sal marcano
who's the head of the time off in new
Bordeaux he actually you can go on
youtube and watch his testimony before
Congress and I can't remember the exact
number but basically every question he
pleads the fifth isn't the fact that
it's a phony job
you don't talk tomatoes at all the way I
would do my family no no no if it's not
a phony job tell me what amazes them I
felt a lot of people and y'all you have
been able to mention one dimension one
person with automated code so even as
you go through the open world what
you're doing is specifically targeting
aspects of Salman Khan owes criminal
organization for example there's some
guys on drugs there's some you know
there's maybe there's a guy selling you
know stolen construction equipment and
you take them out and what you're doing
is you're damaging marcano on a street
level because all that the money flows
up in the mob
so by taking out the money there it
impacts everyone above them and what it
does is exposes everyone as you move
your way up the ladder
again one of the very first things we
did when working on mafia 3 was look
back at mafia 2 and say ok well what are
the things that we're done really well
I'm off you two and where are the areas
where we know we need to improve based
on you know feedback and reviews and our
own just impressions of playing the game
and I think you know one of the things
that that game did really really well
was create this amazing sense of time
and place like that city Empire Bay is
incredible and it's incredibly detailed
and it feels like a main character as
you play the game one of the things we
knew we can improve upon was the
open-world nature of the game and make
sure that there was a plenty of you know
kind of gameplay in the open-world but
we didn't want to go so far as to kind
of create this free-for-all where it was
just a bunch of random unconnected you
know open-world activities I think the
secret to kind of figuring out how to
make a living open-world like this is
starting very very high level knowing
what the story is that you want to tell
about your city and for us new bordo the
story was the south in 1968 and being
able to inform every decision in every
part of the city around that you know
what feels dangerous what feels sexy
what feels poppin as you've described it
while also feeling true to the Mafia
franchise and then just kind of drilling
down deeper and deeper in that what kind
of moments can we communicate what kind
of moments can we convey what kind of
dialogue can you have for two characters
just walking around the street what kind
of reactions can they have to Lincoln
clay our protagonist as he's walking
down the street you know just constantly
articulating and building on that until
we've got this I make it sound simple
but this this sort of vast world of
characters who you know as a player you
can explore and seek out or just kind of
stumble upon as you're going from one
mission to the next sounds like Hanson
marries a little agitated you know or
the directive was let's make sure that
there's plenty to do in the open world
but that everything the player is doing
in the open world either drives forward
Lincoln's quest to tear down the Italian
mob or his kind of you know quest to
build up his own family give me some of
you may we're locking down the French
war you know there there's an urgency to
Lincoln's quest and his mission and we
want to make sure that you know it
didn't feel weird and discordant that
there were all these other activities
that you could do in the game where
you're like why wouldn't we can be doing
that when you know he's trying to do
these other things and he knows he's got
kind of a timeline to do it and before
you know the world hits him back in
hangar 13 XY's knew Bordeaux is a
character in itself it drives the action
sets the tone introduces us to mystery
conflict and paranoia but what's a city
without citizens
what's a town without politics what's
new Bordeaux without its crime its
tension and its people the ones who walk
its streets and navigate the world they
live in that's what we're focusing on in
the next and final episode of this
series the year 1968 and the way it
shapes mafia threes cast the problems
they face the ghosts that haunt them and
the way they're shaped by one of
America's darkest hours how can these
moments flesh out 1968 how can they make
new Bordeaux feel like a living City
it's populated by people who have
thoughts feelings opinions and wants
desires that are all human you know it's
not just random chatter going on it's
actually here's somebody who needs to
pay their rent and they're there
struggling with that here's somebody
who's strung out on drugs and
here's how they're gonna figure out how
they're gonna get their fix here's
somebody's opinion on Cellmark oh no
being the crime boss at the top of the
pyramid in their city and that sense of
pervasive corruption going on there and
hey there's some black guy going around
killing a bunch of mafia mobsters what
does that mean for me and my family you
know making the world feel like it's
lived in for 1968 but also make me feel
like it's reactive to Lincoln Clay as a
character I think was very very
important so we we've just had to kind
of figure out what some of those
interesting moments are and then where
we can fill it out throughout the world
but now
have you way
you